[Music]
before tea cake good morning Hank
hi eggs Larry about a second after
Phyllis said that she looked at me and
said well I guess he could have gathered
that we were getting married and indeed
that's an awfully nice dress to wear to
a cocktail party but anyway thanks to
Brotherhood 2.0 viewers and my cousin's
in-law Phyllis and Blake for their
introductions Hank it was a weekend of
crowds first I was at Book Expo America
probably the biggest book thing in the
country and it was extremely crowded but
Hank you want to know the great thing
about book expert free books free books
everywhere you can take as many as you'd
like as long as you're subtle about it
thanks to maureen johnson and scott
westerfeld's Han for their cameos but
Book Expo isn't all about collecting
books it's also about collecting comic
books for you Hank
look manga I even got you a poster plus
I got some other sweet swag that I'm
gonna be giving away on the Brotherhood
2.0 forum just as soon as you launch it
Hank look at Harry Potter in bag form I
got home went to bed got up at 4:15 and
flew to Decatur Alabama about a month
ago I was wearing my seersucker suit
ironically today I'm wearing it not
ironically Hank this was my first time
watching two Brotherhood 2.0 viewers get
married and let me tell you it's a
magical thing Hank everyone was excited
about the first marriage between
Brotherhood 2.0 viewers I mean the
Catholic Church was so excited that they
sent like 14 priests to officiate also
there was one bishop and a cardinal Hank
they're like 200 Cardinals in the entire
world
Hank as you may or may not know it's the
Cardinals who pick the next pope every
Cardinal under the age of 80 is allowed
to go and help pick the next pope so I
figured this was gonna be a great time
for me to lobby for the kind of Pope
I've been looking for but sadly I don't
think this guy's under 80 nonetheless he
did a fantastic job at the wedding
Phyllis and Blake just seemed so happy
together I mean look at them up there
they're just giddy I kept wondering what
they were talking about and then I
realized the evil baby orphanage
everybody's talking about it Hank it's
huge the other way I knew that people
were really really excited about the
wedding between two Brotherhood 2.0
viewers is that a lot of people came
six hundred people and as I looked over
this crowd of people I couldn't help but
think man if I happen to have a super
drug-resistant strain of tuberculosis a
lot of people are in a lot of trouble
anyway Hank the reception was also a
great time Randy gave a high-five to the
infant baby Jesus who was inexplicably
doing jazz hands Phyllis and Blake cut
the cake as you can see although you
can't see Phyllis because she happens to
be the same height and wearing the same
color as the cake itself pink even
though Blake got married on Saturday he
took the time probably while he was
still in his marital bed to write a
comment that I thought was very
interesting about liquid coal what Blake
said is that while cars should never be
powered by coal it does make sense to
try to develop cleaner coal technologies
because there's no way that countries
like India and China are going to
completely phase out coal in the next 50
years to look forward to the
environmental discussion on the
Brotherhood 2.0 forum by the way have I
mentioned the forum enough times today
anyway Hank was a beautiful wedding and
a beautiful reception but in the end
weddings aren't about the tastiness of
the cake or the deliciousness of the pot
roast or even about whether or not a
cardinal officiates at the wedding Hank
what I saw again at Blake and Phyllis's
wedding and what I saw your wedding and
what I felt at my wedding is that
weddings are truly about any of those
things
they're about how cute it is when kids
dance so Hank I think we're both happy
about the first nerdfighter marriage and
I think we're both hoping for many many
more they're honeymooning in banff right
now so i don't know wow that's really
fun word to say bamp bamp Hank I'll see
you tomorrow